bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat pour voir ou revoir les temps
forts du projet de loi à croissance
activités et égalité des chances
économiques que vous connaissez aussi
sous le nom de projet de loi Macron vous
le savez pendant les vacances les
travaux parlementaires sont suspendus
l'examen de ce texte ne fait pas
exception il reprendra à partir du 4 mai
prochain mais je vous propose
aujourd'hui de revoir le vote d'une
partie du volet sur les professions
réglementées à un volet hautement
stratégique les sénateurs sont bien
décidés à imprimer leur marque sur cette
partie du texte ils ont donc freiné les
ardeurs du gouvernement en limitant en
partie la libéralisation si l'on prend
par exemple l'implantation des notaires
les sénateurs ont précisé que cette
implantation ne serait purement et
parfaitement libre que dans certaines
zones où il y a un déficit d'office des
zones préalablement définies par le ou
la garde des sceaux avec la vie de
l'Autorité de la concurrence tout de
suite direction la séance
nous passons à l'article 13 Madame
Brigitte Gontier Morin à la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
porte sur trois questions importantes la
première celle de la postulation dans le
ressort des cours d'appel que le
gouvernement voudrait rendre définitif
et généralisé et que la commission
spéciale cette souhaiterait voir passer
dans un premier temps par une phase
d'expérimentation
cette question est déterminante pour
l'avenir de la profession car elle
pourrait annoncer la mort des petits
barreaux dans des départements déjà
affectés par les disparitions de
nombreux services publics l'accès au
droit pour les Justiciers serait ainsi
remis en cause comme il a été avec la
fermeture de nombreux tribunaux ce
serait un pas de plus vers un traitement
inéquitable sur nos territoires
contraire aux principes de notre
République le Gouvernement a su mettre
en avant pardon les principes
républicains en ce début d'année il
conviendrait aujourd'hui de les voir se
réaliser par des actes pour tous les
citoyens et quel que soit leur lieu de
résidence
passée par une phase d'expérimentation
pourrait effectivement permettre une
étude d'impact dans le réel mais nous
savons tous que c'est aussi la porte
ouverte à la généralisation à plus ou
moins brève échéant bah bref échéance
comme la noter le rapport le risque de
dévitalisation de certains territoires
doit être pris en considération avec le
risque que des avocats situés sur le
territoire du tribunal se voit dépossédé
de nombreux dossiers 70 à 80 % selon le
bâtonnier de Libourne cela peut conduire
aussi une réelle précarisation de la
profession comme l'a indiqué une note de
l'Observatoire du Conseil national des
barreaux qui fait apparaître que dans le
classement des 10 barreaux dans les dans
lesquels les revenus moyens des avocats
sont les plus faibles on retrouve 5 des
barreaux dans une zone de multiples
postulation trois barreaux de la cour
d'appel de Paris Seine-Saint-Denis
Val-de-Marne Essonne ainsi que les
barreaux de Libourne et Alès
l'expérimentation a été effectuée sur
ces villes on peut donc s'appuyer sur
ces effets produits pourquoi alors
vouloir en ajouter une autre c'est de
notre point de vue
inutile pour ceux qui nous concerne nous
sommes opposés dans la mesure où nous
condessons donc déjà les résultats à
cette expérimentation nouvelle
programmez ainsi la mort des petits
barreaux la précarisation de la
profession y compris en passant par
cette phase née notre point de vue par
acceptable la deuxième question posée
mes chefs collègues par cet article et
celle d'un assouplissement du régime de
création des bureaux secondaires dès
lors que sont que ce sont des bureaux
réels avec une réelle activité la
Commission a maintenu la demande
d'autorisation qui devait dans le texte
présenter au Sénat se transformer en
simple information du bureau le
troisième sujet traité par cet article
et celui de soumettre dans le texte
initial à la DGC RF les conventions
d'honoraires des avocats le bâtonnier
serait en quelque sorte d'est saisie de
cette question puisqu'il ne serait pas
associé aux perquisitions éventuelles et
donc le secret professionnel risque de
ne pas être garanti cet article ainsi
rédigé par la commission représente donc
un progrès indignable par rapport au
texte d'origine à la seule exception
vous l'aurez compris de
l'expérimentation pour la postulation
dans le ressort des cours d'appel
merci beaucoup
alors nous commençons par
quatre amendements identiques qui sont
des amendements de suppression
alors c'est Madame Gauthier Moreau non
pardon excusez-moi allez-y je vous en
prie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre donc comme vient de le dire ma
collègue Brigitte Gontier Morin
l'article 13
introduisait dans sa version initiale
l'extension du périmètre de postulation
des avocats du TGI à la cour d'appel
bien que très largement atténué en
commission cet article n'en conserve pas
moins l'esprit initial qui aboutit à un
bouleversement complet de la carte
judiciaire j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
préciser que cet élargissement n'a pas
fait l'objet d'une étude d'impact et que
cela mériterait au moins un renvoi en
commission pour évaluation précise des
conséquences de cet article la
commission spéciale à certes restreint
le dispositif pour n'en faire plus
qu'une expérimentation dans le ressort
de deux cours d'appel pendant une durée
de trois années cependant la seule
attitude positive pour nous aurait été
de supprimer ces dispositions en
l'absence d'évaluation cette
expérimentation peut sembler constituée
à un progrès mais ce faisant et en
réalité elle entérine le principe même
de l'extension tout en ne l'assumant pas
et remet en cause le monopole de la
postulation des avocats au ressort de
chaque tribunal de grande instance cela
est d'autant plus vrai qu'une
expérimentation de l'extension du
périmètre cela a été dit a déjà été
faite à Bordeaux à Libourne à Nîmes et à
l'est et qu'elle n'a pas d'effet
positifs bien au contraire cet
élargissement aurait des conséquences
sur l'équilibre économique et numérique
des barreaux notamment dans les régions
rurales mais pas seulement et sur le
maillage territorial de la justice
en portant le périmètre de postulation
des avocats du TGI à la cour d'appel on
constaterait l'apparition de désert
juridique après les déserts médicaux ce
qui remet en cause l'accès de tous les
citoyens à la justice
la diminution du nombre d'avocats dans
les barreaux ou les effectifs sont
moindres constituent une source de
difficultés juridique liée à
l'éloignement des de l'avocat des
justiciables sans compter la
répercussion en termes de coûts que cet
éloignement ne manquera pas d'avoir pour
ses justiciables ce phénomène
d'élargissement aboutit en effet une
concentration des cabinets d'avocats
autour des cours d'appel au regroupement
dans les mêmes zones voire dans les
mêmes cabinets c'est comme pour les
notaires là où on pourra gagner de
l'argent une étude menée par le Conseil
national du barreau démontre en effet
que cette mesure affecterait en priorité
les cabinets de petite taille dans les
barreaux aux effectifs les plus réduits
loin des grandes villes cela signifie
donc tout simplement la fin d'une
justice de proximité par une
concentration excessive de la présence
des avocats dans de grandes villes au
détriment des zones moins peuplées déjà
désertées par les services publics et on
peut ajouter que ça va dans le sens
contraire de ce qui de la réforme de
la justice
chers collègues le 288 rectifié bis
n'est pas défendu le 338 non plus
ainsi que le 769
donc
quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur Pilet sur le 14 oui
chers collègues encore un sujet
évidemment difficile nous allons
retrouver notre calme et nous allons
l'aborder avec la responsabilité qui est
la sagesse qui nous caractérise
la postulation c'est un problème sa
suppression ou en tout cas sa
modification est un problème très
important pour le maillage territorial
je vais m'expliquer
la postulation ça oblige à passer par un
avocat
local lorsque une dossier et à très
devant le tribunal de grande instance ça
lui crée donc cet avocat local une
clientèle nécessaire
qui prévient d'autres barreaux clientèle
institutionnels ou autre à l'évidence ça
représente un chiffre d'affaires
si vous supprimez totalement la
postulation ce que je sens bien et
l'objectif de certains termes qu'est-ce
qui arrivera
les câlinés d'avocats se regrouperont au
siège de la cour d'appel et auront
éventuellement un bureau secondaire un
bureau fort
dans les villes
dépendantes de cette cour d'appel
n'ayons plus d'avocats ayant des
barreaux qui n'auront plus assez
d'avocat
pour en raison du fait que le chiffre
d'affaires globale du barreau aura
diminué à qui demanderez-vous d'aller
assurer les garde à vue le samedi le
dimanche ou dans la semaine devant le
juge d'instruction dans les gendarmerie
à l'autre bout du département sa pose
problème parce que il y a un chiffre
d'affaires de la population mais faut
pas oublier que les avocats en
contrepartie ils assurent une large
partie du service public le service
public qu'on a voulu à travers les
gardes à vue et l'aide juridictionnelle
donc il faut toucher à la postulation
avec beaucoup de prudence beaucoup de
prudence c'est la raison pour laquelle
on peut parfaitement comprendre
l'amendement de suppression parfaitement
comprend néanmoins bien compris que je
suis un pragmatique
la procédure parlementaire fait que si
on annule complètement la volonté
gouvernementale sur ce point qu'est-ce
qui se passera au niveau de la chambre
de l'Assemblée nationale le texte du
Gouvernement repassera et nous n'aurons
pas pu apporter en l'espèce une
plus-value dictée par une analyse
intelligente de l'économie locale c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai proposé un
système
qui est un système qui n'est pas parfait
je le conçois parfaitement mais qui a au
moins l'avantage de vérifier si la
position du gouvernement est dangereuse
comme je le pense ou si on peut y aller
au cas où elle n'aurait pas eu d'effet
tout ça c'est des mots
tout ça c'est des mots mais mais on a
des points pour savoir ce qui se passe
lorsque la postulation est supprimée ou
lorsqu'elle est éclatée on l'a sur les
barreaux de Bordeaux Libourne
oui ça a été expérimenté et Nîmes Alès
et alors sur ce point comme toujours
lorsqu'il y a pas de d'études d'impact
particulièrement précise on peut dire
tout et n'importe quoi j'ai tout de même
de bonne références puisque je reprends
celle de la Chancellerie qui indique que
le batonnier de Libourne que ces
confrères auraient perdu depuis la mise
en place de la multiposimation 70 à 80%
des dossiers de postulation
pas fabuleux pour le barreau de Libourne
on note de une note de l'Observatoire du
CNB du 7 octobre 2014 dont j'attends
qu'elle soit éventuellement contredite
ce qui n'est pas le cas jusqu'à présent
fait apparaître que dans le classement
des 10 barreaux dans lesquels les
revenus moyens des avocats sont les plus
faibles on retrouve 5 des barreaux
situés dans une zone de multiples
possibilités
de Paris
Seine-Saint-Denis Val-de-Marne Essonne
ainsi que les barreaux de Libourne et
Alès c'est à dire que le seul étude
d'impact que nous avons le terrain
il est défavorable
à la position gouvernante alors ce que
je propose c'est
attendons et voyons encore une fois
c'est pas cette réforme là qui dans 15
jours va faire que nous allons pouvoir
rembourser notre endettement national
le je propose donc que nous
expérimentions
de manière précise
quel est l'impact de la mesure
gouvernementale
expérimentation dont d'ailleurs ce que
je viens de vous dire ne rend pas compte
parce que Bordeaux Libourne c'est pas
une
impossibilité de postulation dans toute
la cour d'appel donc la postulation
l'expérimentation que je demande est
beaucoup plus large et sera beaucoup
plus précise alors encore une fois je
comprends que ce n'est pas une situation
idéale mais c'est la seule qui si les
collègues députés ont envie de ne pas
aller trop loin c'est la seule qui
peuvent éventuellement accepter je
comprends les positions radicales c'est
la dictature parlementaire je vous
laisse cette
ah la technique oui vous voyez comme
quoi le
et voilà pourquoi je vous propose cette
mesure particulière j'ai bien compris
qu'elle ne plaisait à personne mais ne
plaisant à personne et pourra peut-être
satisfaire tout le monde si tout le
monde peut essayer de trouver un
consensus
bien alors Monsieur le Ministre
des favorable
je vais mettre au voie donc l'amendement
oui je vous en prie vous avez la parole
présenté par le groupe communiste
étonnamment qui a été présenté par
d'autres groupes il n'a pas été soutenu
par le groupe Union centré puisque au
compte de collègues étaient présents
mais cette question objectivement
partage la vie des groupes elle justifie
de notre part quelques mots
d'explications pour vous dire tout
simplement que la proposition de la
Commission
d'expérimentation pour les raisons qui
ont été expliquées par monsieur le
rapporteur m'apparaît pertinente et ceci
vaudra explication de vote dans le sens
du rejet de l'amendement deux questions
sont posées à travers l'article 13 la
question de la postulation la maintenir
ou pas la maintenir et deuxièmement la
question de sa territorialisation sur la
question du maintien de la postulation
je n'entends pas de débat il n'y a
d'ailleurs
le sens aucun enjeu financier pour le
gouvernement puisqu'il a déjà obtenu la
suppression des états de frais à
l'exception des procédures de saisie
immobilière ou delicitations et puis on
buterait immédiatement si on voulait
porter atteinte à la postulation sur la
question de la responsabilité des
professionnels puisque la responsabilité
d'un professionnel vis-à-vis de son
client vis-à-vis de l'usager elle se
joue notamment vis-à-vis de la
juridiction dans le cadre de la
postulation donc oui la postulation est
indispensable reste la question de la
territorisation vous venez nous venons
d'entendre des explications à la fois de
notre collègue du groupe communiste mais
aussi du rapporteur sur les éléments qui
conduiraient à souhaiter le maintien
d'une postulation au niveau de chacun
des tribunaux de grande instance j'en
partage globalement les éléments éviter
une France à deux vitesses sur le plan
quelque part si vous me permettez le
raccourci un peu hasardeuse la
postulation au stade de la cour d'appel
c'est la loi maptam appliquée au monde
de la justice l'aspect métropolisation
donc je partage l'idée de garder ce
maillage et territoire en même temps je
reconnais que la profession peut-être
partagée elle est largement favorable à
la postulation au niveau de chaque
tribunal chaque tribunal de grande
instance mais il a pu y avoir aussi dans
la profession des avis divergents
là-dessus quels sont finalement les
éléments qui me paraissent justifier le
fait d'en rester au texte de la
commission premièrement ceci nous a été
très bien expliqué le fait qu'il s'agit
d'une disposition d'équilibre entre une
suppression que l'on aurait bien
souhaité de l'article 13 et le fait de
ne pas aller à une situation
d'affrontement vis-à-vis de l'Assemblée
me paraît effectivement un élément
pertinent et nous connaissons tous le
point de vue du président du Sénat
consistant à avoir un travail col
collaboratif aux coopératif ou
co-construction bien sûr qui est le
propre du bicamérisme entre l'Assemblée
et le Sénat je rajoute un dernier
argument au cas où le gouvernement ne
serait pas convaincu par la pertinence
de la proposition de la Commission en
disant très simplement monsieur le
ministre que
vouloir imposer si je me permets de
l'expression une postulation au stade
l'accord d'appel ce sont des coûts
supplémentaires pour la justice
française je m'explique là-dessus à un
moment donné quel que soit les éléments
informatiques ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon le RPVA qui gère aujourd'hui les
procédures de mise en état
toute procédure assez spécificité et à
un moment donné il faut que le praticien
et le magistrat puisse avoir une
relation directe au-delà de la qualité
des tuyauterie informatique qui sont
aujourd'hui en place et pour pouvoir
avoir cette discussion entre les
conseils et les magistrats il faut bien
qu'il y ait cette notion
territorialisation et chaque fois qu'on
va s’ann écarter ceci va obliger de
mettre en place des dispositifs pour
gérer les dysfonctionnements autrement
dit plus vous voudrez avoir une
postulation au stade de la cour d'appel
monsieur Miss plus vous aurez besoin de
magistrats plus vous aurez besoin de
greffiers pour arriver à traiter les
dysfonctionnements qui vont se produire
donc que l'on raisonne technique
économique ou que l'on raisonne comme la
fait le rapporteur dans le souhait de
pouvoir trouver un point de vue de
co-construction entre l'Assemblée et le
Sénat la solution à laquelle est arrivée
à la commission spéciale me paraît une
solution de sagesse et même si au sein
du groupe Idy Union centriste il a pu y
avoir des éléments divergents qui
s'étaient matérialisés par l'amendement
qui a été évoqué il me semble que la
direction à la bonne c'est pour ça à
titre d'explication de vote que je
voterai contre l'amendement qui vous a
été présenté merci merci Monsieur
bonnecareire monsieur Bigot à la parole
madame la Présidente merci chers
collègues je pense qu'il faut pas se
tromper de débat
il faut distinguer clairement les choses
de quoi parle-t-on la postulation pour
les avocats c'était l'exercice des
professions d'avoué devant les tribunaux
de grande instance et uniquement sur un
certain nombre de matière qui sont de
moins en moins importantes et où le
considère qu'il fallait qu'il y ait un
auxiliaire de justice l'avouer qui
dépose les écrits et puis un avocat
pouvait plaider
pour le reste les avocats lorsqu'il y a
représentation soit la personne peut se
défendre tout seul soit elle doit être
représentée elle peut être représentée
que par un avocat mais de toute la
France entière devant toutes les
juridictions prudentales les chambres
sociales des cours d'appel etc les
tribunaux correctionnels donc on parle
de très très peu de choses et lorsque
j'entends dire que c'est une façon de
défendre les territoires et je pense que
la Chancellerie n'y est pas complètement
hostile parce qu'effectivement il y a un
vrai problème
comment fera-t-on demain pour avoir des
avocats qui font de l'aide
juridictionnelle s'ils n'ont pas un
petit monopole qui serait effectivement
celui de l'imposture mais qui va fondre
comme neige au soleil alors le texte
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale maintient
un certain nombre de procédures ces
immobilières etc qui effectivement
seront réservés à ces avocats avec un
tarif des émoluments mais pour le reste
je pense que la défense de la profession
à laquelle j'ai appartenu jusqu'au
premier avril de l'année 2014
c'est d'abord de se bouger on barreau de
Strasbourg dans lequel je suis rentré en
1975 nous étions 140 ils sont
aujourd'hui plus de 1000 la réalité
c'est qu'en contredit à un jeune
confrère allez vous installer dans un
petit barreau non pas dans un petit
barreau parce que le barreau est petit
mais parce qu'il y a des usagers il y a
des habitants qui ont besoin d'avocat et
y compris pour que ces avocats
éventuellement plaidèrent c'est ça ce
qu'il faut que la profession soit c'est
se battre effectivement comme un secteur
concurrentiel en essayant d'être présent
sur le terrain et pourquoi n'y a-t-il
pas d'avocats dans certains barreaux de
la grande couronne parisienne parce que
la clientèle est essentiellement en aide
juridictionnelle et que ce qu'ils
encaissent en aide juridictionnelle leur
permet pas de vivre correctement et cela
aussi n'est toujours pas réglé quel que
soit les gouvernements donc le vrai
sujet sur la présence territoriale c'est
effectivement comment la profession va
s'organiser pour montrer à des jeunes
qui veulent y aller mais c'est la même
chose pour des médecins les jeunes
aujourd'hui veulent rester dans leur
secteur universitaire ils veulent rester
très grande ville il faut que l'on
arrive dans le monde rural à leur faire
dire que il vaut mieux être riche dans
une petite province et pouvoir se
déplacer en TGV pour aller de temps en
temps à Paris ou dans la grande ville
que de rester forcément dans la grande
ville et d'être pauvre c'est ça la
réalité qu'il faut leur expliquer dès
qu'ils ont entendu les écoles d'avocat
ensuite effectivement le texte qui est
proposé va poser à terme les problèmes
de l'organisation territoriale mais moi
je pense que il vaut mieux que l'on
s'oppose un jour la question peut-être
dans le code de l'accès aux droits que
vous avez souhaité comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour qu'un justiciable en France
puisse effectivement avoir le droit à
une défense quelle que soit ses moyens
et même s'il est un pauvre ouvrier qui
doit se défendre devant les prud'hommes
ou qui doit se défendre devant une
juridiction du tribunal de grande
instance parce que il demande le divorce
ou que on demande le divorce voilà les
réalités c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense que la suppression de l'article
qui est proposé est inutile et je
reviendrai sur le fond de l'article
parce que je pense que à force de
vouloir reporter reporter on ne fait pas
évoluer les choses et que la justice
dans laquelle vous avez su à un moment
donné supprimer des tribunaux de grande
instance et ce qu'on a réfléchi au fait
que le justiciable de Dole était obligé
d'aller à Lons-le-Saunier alors qu'il
n'y a aucune liaison on sait pas
préoccupé de savoir s'il y avait des
avocats qui allaient disparaître c'est
ça la réalité les avocats sont restés à
Dole mais les tribunaux sont partis
merci beaucoup Monsieur Jean des Essarts
des avocats de mon groupe pour qu'il
m'explique effectivement alors là on
sent qu'il y a des personnes qui
connaissent très bien
et à l'Assemblée nationale vous
souhaitiez étendre le monopole de la
postulation ou non qu'est-ce qui était
le votre
la proposition initiale de l'Assemblée
donc là j'avais l'impression que c'était
de vouloir dire la postulation au regard
on l'étend au cours d'appel je crois que
c'était ça le l'objet donc c'était une
extension
où c'était un glissement
bon donc là il y aura une demande
d'explication ensuite vous monsieur le
rapporteur vous dites faut pas toujours
dans votre démarche de temps d'une
perche de ne pas aller contre
l'Assemblée nationale vous dites faut
que je trouve quelque chose de médian
alors c'est là que je comprends pas
parce que j'avais compris que à
l'Assemblée il voulait étendre la
postulation vous monsieur le rapporteur
vous êtes plutôt pour la postulation et
vous l'avez défendu pour les territoires
ah non c'est plus mitigé mais vous avez
dit je suis prêt à faire une
conciliation avec l'Assemblée et le
gouvernement donc
pour dire que je n'ai pas compris mais
il y a rien de grave
mais si vous pouviez à un moment
éclairer la ce que veut vraiment le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée est-ce que
vous vous modérez monsieur le rapporteur
ça nous permettrait nous de savoir où on
en est ça c'est la première question et
la deuxième question puisque monsieur le
rapporteur il a dit j'ai fait un panaché
j'ai essayé de tenir compte de mon avis
enfin de la vie du Sénat et de la vie de
l'Assemblée nationale en disant que
c'est l'équilibre pour faire un
équilibre il faut être deux donc la
question qui est posée soit au
socialiste soit à monsieur le ministre
c'est est-ce que vous acceptez vous
c'est équilibre et est-ce que ou alors
allez-vous le remettre en cause lors de
la CMP parce que si on vote une
situation d'équilibre mais qui n'est pas
reprise par le ministre et que
l'assemblée est bien le fait tomber
autant afficher clairement la couleur de
ce qu'on veut sans se préoccuper de
maintenir un équilibre donc il y a deux
questions une petite explication
Nathalie Goulet vous avez la parole oui
mais le président monsieur le ministre
la question de la postulation ou de sa
suppression c'est quand même posé depuis
très longtemps c'est pas un sujet
franchement nouveau
qui revient un peu comme ça comme mars
en Carême c'est quelque chose qui arrive
quand même assez fréquemment quand on a
dans cette maison on discuter de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire de Madame
Dati nous avons été un certain nombre à
mettre en garde le gouvernement de
l'époque en lui disant qu'on allait
quand même risquer de graves difficultés
d'autant qu'on n'avait pas d'études
d'impact et puis là-dessus est arrivé la
suppression des avoués à la cour d'appel
ce qui est aussi a posé un certain
nombre de difficultés techniques et
autres et aujourd'hui moi j'ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention notre rapport
et et aussi notre collègue bonne Carrère
qui vient de s'exprimer parce que ce qui
va se passer c'est que le risque quand
même de déperdition de personnel capable
de supporter
les actions et moi je pense surtout en
matière pénale j'ai dans mon département
comme beaucoup d'autres j'ai gardé j'ai
eu la chance de garder deux cours à deux
tribunaux de grande instance parce que
j'ai un une prison extrêmement
importante à Argentan mais quand vous
avez des garde à vue quand vous avez la
présence de l'avocat de plus en plus
requis notamment pour des motifs liés
aux impératifs de la Cour européenne de
justice qui nous dit que la présence de
l'avocat est un est impérative à telle
heure et à telle heure à tel moment de
la procédure lorsque vous avez des
procédures accélérées lorsque vous avez
besoin de permanence de du droit vous
allez vous retrouver devant des
difficultés extrêmement sérieuses
extrêmement sérieuse et moi je suis je
suis plutôt inquiète de l'aspect
matériel et des effets de ce que vous
nous proposez pour pour les relations et
pour la permanence du droit parce que ça
pas poser des difficultés et encore une
fois je crois qu'on va en plus subir le
contrecoup de la suppression des avouées
parce que là au moins on avait le face à
face c'était pour dans beaucoup de cas
des boîtes aux lettres mais dans
beaucoup de cas il donnait quand même un
sérieux coup de main en matière
procédural et on a plus non plus cet
échelon là donc moi j'attire simplement
la tension sur le fait qu'on a besoin de
cette permanence du droit et qu'on
risque quand même une déperdition
d'énergie et une déperdition humaine à
force de de ne pas faire des réformes
complètes alors on l'a fait complètement
et c'est ce qu'on avait proposé certains
d'entre nous au moment de la suppression
des avouées il vous supprimez la
postulation devant la cour d'appel
parfait alors supprimons la postulation
complètement et revoyons complètement le
système mais là on est toujours au
milieu du guet voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup y a-t-il d'autres prises
de parole monsieur harnais je vous en
prie
un petit peu
perplexe dans la discussion puisque
après avoir écouté l'excellent collègue
ça me permettra peut-être de ne pas
avoir à présenter l'amendement
qui vient
la postulation innocente en tout cas
pour le groupe et dans la perception que
nous avons c'est effectivement non pas
un doigt octroyer aux avocats mais une
garantie pour le justiciable et la
question essentielle nous semblait était
la question du maillage territorial
alors je ne voudrais pas revenir sur les
exemples d'Alès de Nîmes de Dunkerque
etc et il y en a plein d'autres
mais probablement pour ajouter encore un
petit peu de piment ou
toxique c'est un ingrédient de ma région
afin de répondre à la problématique du
mariage
territorial et puisque la
postulation en tout cas la suppression
de la postulation n'a pas été concluante
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas répondre à
cette problématique du maillage
en faisant en sorte qu'il y ait une
postulation
départementale en lieu et place de la
proposition de postulation devant
l'ensemble des tribunaux de grande
instance du ressort de la cour d'appel
et devant la dico l'appel
je vais donc mettre au bois l'amendement
numéro 14 qui est un amendement de
suppression avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune monsieur Bouvard
n'est pas là donc il n'est pas défendu
monsieur Arnel
il est retiré
les deux amendements suivants toujours
en discussion commune monsieur Bigot le
cet amendement sera extrêmement bref
c'est on a déjà avancé c'est ou bien on
va effectivement petit à petit vers la
suppression de la postulation et pour
répondre à notre collègue
je pense qu'effectivement il peut y
avoir un moment donné un problème de
présence d'avocats sur certains
territoires notamment pour répondre en
matière pénale par exemple aux exigences
de la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme et à la présence en garde à vue
la présence devant les juridictions mais
ça c'est une responsabilité collective
et le fond d'accès aux droits doit
permettre notamment de mieux rémunérer
et si des jeunes qui sont souvent
intéressés par le droit pénal mais qui
pense qu'il n'est pas suffisamment ré
lucratif sauf pour les grandes affaires
si des jeunes savent que sur tel
territoire ils auront une
solvabilisation de leurs clientèle ils y
viendront
à moins qu'il est vraiment pas envie de
vivre dans le monde rural pour être
clair certains autres sujets qu'on ne
réglera pas par la postulation et donc
je pense que on ne peut pas
perpétuellement retarder retarder les
choses je dirais que ce qu'a prévu
l'Assemblée nationale c'est déjà une
forme de compromis c'est de dire bon on
fait pas on ne supprime pas la
postulation de manière générale sur
toute la France
on le réserve à des territoires de cour
d'appel et franchement aujourd'hui
d'aller
m'excuser moi je connais mieux ma région
que d'autres mais d'aller de Strasbourg
à Colmar à Mulhouse ou Mulhouse à
Strasbourg ou à Saverne c'est pas un
problème jadis on y allait à cheval et
le tribunal de grande instance avaient
retard aujourd'hui on y est en TER ou en
voiture de manière si rapide et
l'informatique permet quand même d'avoir
un contact avec les juridictions le RPVA
notamment qui est complètement différent
donc
retarder pour de toute façon y arriver
je pense qu'elle n'a pas d'intérêt c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre groupe a
simplement repris de le texte de
l'Assemblée nationale qui me paraît déjà
à une politique des petits pas car tôt
ou tard de toute façon cette notion de
monopole de la postulation disparaîtra
ce qui restera par contre je le souhaite
et c'est ça la notion d'auxiliaire de
justice et de dire il faut des avocats
il faut des gens qui prêtaient serment
qui est une déontologie pour défendre
les gens en justice pour les représenter
que ce soit les grandes entreprises les
petites et moyennes mais aussi le
particulier qu'on oublie trop dans cette
discussion sur la réforme des
professions réglementées
merci beaucoup le 180 n'est pas défendu
quelle est la vie monsieur pilier sur
l'amendement défendu par Monsieur Bigot
c'est-à-dire 725
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
de vous obliger dans un cas un avocat
accepté d'être commis d'office et que
vous lui interdisez en même temps de
postuler auprès de ce tribunal
il me semble donc plutôt de que de
vouloir absolument rétablir la rédaction
de l'Assemblée nationale il faudrait
tenter de régler cette contradiction
outre d'ailleurs qu'au point du
fonctionnement des barreaux et des
ordres ça poserait une certaine
difficulté puisque un avocat se
trouverait soumis à l'autorité d'un
bâtonnier au barreau principal et à
l'autorité de l'autre va tenir dans le
bureau secondaire puisque c'est le
bâtonnier qui effectue les commissions
d'office enfin l'amendement rétablit la
compétence de la DGCCRF pour contrôler
les conventions d'honoraires
c'est un point sur lequel j'ai attiré
l'attention du gouvernement dès les
auditions
s'il s'agit uniquement et là encore il y
a une ouverture s'il s'agit uniquement
de constater la remise ou non d'un
document c'est-à-dire la convention
d'honoraires qui fixe le mode de
rémunération de l'avocat pourquoi pas
d'un contrôle formel est-ce qu'il y a
une convention est-ce qu'il y en a pas
mais s'il s'agit de s'assurer que
ce document était suffisamment complet
ou qu'il correspondait bien compte tenu
de l'affaire à ce que l'avocat était
obligé de prévoir pour son client il
faudra entrer dans le dossier et là se
pose un problème de secret professionnel
d'ailleurs celui qui peut entrer dans le
dossier c'est le bâtonnier
j'ajoute enfin que la DGCCRF pourrait
déployer l'ensemble de ses prérogatives
pour assurer ce contrôle y compris ses
pouvoirs de perquisition de saisie or
qu'il n'y a pas sur ce texte cet
amendement de précaution ce qui concerne
l'intervention du Bâtonnier
contrairement à ce qui se passe pour une
perquisition en matière pénale donc sur
ce dernier point alors sur l'ensemble de
l'amendement pour les deux premiers
points que j'ai indiqué il ne peut être
que défavorable sur le troisième point
si j'attends de l'information du
gouvernement mais si ce qui m'a été
indiqué au cours de la de l'audition de
la déchets CCRF s'il contrôle de la
DGCCRF n'est qu'un contrôle formel il
existe bien une convention et qu'à aucun
moment son contrôle ne puisse empiéter
sur le secret professionnel de l'avocat
pourquoi pas
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci Madame le Présidente je vais
donner un avis favorable à cet
amendement et ce qui me permettra de
revenir ce que je n'ai pas encore fait
sur le fond de la réforme et apporter
toutes éclaircissement à monsieur le
sénateur des Essarts je crois quand la
matière pour le coup n'arriveront pas à
nous mettre d'accord sur ce point avec
la commission spéciale on s'en est parlé
parce que je crois vraiment que vous
êtes trop frileux sur le sujet d'abord
je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on se joue
qu'on joue collectivement à se faire
peur de quoi parle-t-on en matière
pénale en matière Prudhomme matière vous
l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas de
postulation territoriale il n'y en a pas
il n'y en a on ne parle que du civil
et c'est la conséquence logique de la
suppression des avouées qui a été déjà
votée en 2011 et donc comment
voulez-vous expliquer que quand vous
avez une affaire pénale votre avocat
peut aller plus dépourvu dans un bar ou
à l'autre bout de la France et donc à
fortiori dans la cour d'appel voisine et
que en matière familiale par exemple
si vous êtes à Chambéry vous devez
passer par la postulation et les
couilles afférents pour divorcer à
Annecy parce que c'est cela dont on
parle donc c'est un prélèvement c'est un
prélèvement sur nos concitoyens c'est
une moins bonne justice et honnêtement
c'est aujourd'hui inexplicable par
rapport à l'organisation générale notre
système juridique donc c'est
véritablement ce qui s'appelle un
archaïs maintenant est-ce que c'est une
profonde des stabilisations le chiffre
d'affaires de la profession d'avocat
c'est environ 11 milliards
et
macroéconomiquement la postulation je
reprends les chiffres du barreau c'est
50 millions alors sauf à ce que c'est 50
millions soit vraiment concentrés dans
quelques barreaux qui seraient
totalement anéanti par cette réforme on
parle pas de quelque chose qui est
macroéconomiquement significatif que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'on le voit
bien c'est pas l'essentiel de la matière
de la profession donc on parle
véritablement d'un ajustement et moi
j'ai bien pris les points que Monsieur
rapporteur cité mais quelle était la
réalité avant la réforme est-ce
expérimentation qui a mis dans votre
classement les barreaux d'alèse de Nîmes
je n'en suis pas sûr nous n'avons
d'ailleurs pas la preuve
donc sur ce sujet là je ne crois pas
d'ailleurs la profession d'avocat n'a
jamais pu fournir des chiffres robuste
pour dire que ce serait une catastrophe
qu'on mette pas qu'on mette fin à la
postulation territoriale ensuite vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
nous avons déjà procédé à un compromis
c'est-à-dire que d'abord on ne dit pas
il y a plus de postulation territoriale
du tout on dit on élargit en effet au
niveau de la cour d'appel premier point
niveau de la cour d'appel deuxièmement
on a dit il y a des matières qui restent
au niveau du tribunal de grande instance
qui ont été définis et qui continueront
à être même en civil toujours plaider
avec la postulation donc on a déjà fait
des aménagements et on part pas dans le
grand bain et donc moi j'avoue que dire
qu'on va passer par l'expérimentation
alors même que c'est une réforme
relativement logique très marginale et
sur laquelle il y a déjà eu des
compromis je trouve que ça n'est pas la
hauteur de l'enjeu il y a un système
vous l'avez dit en effet de
d'informatisation des actes qui est
déployé à 80% précisément en matière
civile précisément en matière civile et
il n'empêche pas si le besoin était
d'aller au contact du magistrat d'abord
de se déplacer ce qui dans beaucoup de
territoire est quand même possible dans
le niveau au niveau du ressort de la
cour d'appel ou de choisir un
correspondant mais l'automaticité de la
postulation sera elle supprimée
mais si besoin est vous pouvez toujours
prendre un correspondance est une
liberté qui reste donc très honnêtement
on parle là de quelque chose qui est
encadré qui est aménagé qui est marginal
qui est le sens de l'histoire je crois
que il faut pas jouer à se faire peur vu
l'ampleur de du sujet vu la réforme que
nous sommes en train de faire
franchement il faut avancer et puis
monsieur le rapporteur je dois dire
faire une expérimentation qui prendra
trois ans qui sera dans un an qui
prendra 3 ans ça veut dire que on ne
bouge pas jusqu'en 2019
bon donc on bouge pour améliorer le bon
fonctionnement du droit pour aller mais
non mais pour parce que c'est justement
très marginal mais pour éviter que dans
les affaires civiles on reste à un
système de postulation territoriale au
niveau de la TGI de la même façon qu'en
2011 on a bougé pour les avouer je pense
même que votre majorité sénatoriale qui
était à l'époque aux affaires étaient
pour et bien c'était beaucoup plus
substantiel de bouger pour les avouer je
peux vous le dire d'ailleurs ça a donné
lieu à indemnisation ce qui n'est pas le
cas d'une telle réforme je pense que il
faut aller au bout de cette logique ne
pas jouer avec les peurs bien au
contraire l'enjeu est circonscrit parce
que c'est un meilleur service à nos
contribuables et honnêtement moi je ne
pense que c'est une forme de mauvais
corporatisme de céder là à cette
pression et de vouloir différer
alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez un présupposé c'est que c'est
bien
l'expérimentation la force de
l'expérimentation c'est qu'on vérifiera
si c'est bien
c'est tout
Nathalie Goulet vous avez la parole
je trouve ce débat même président
monsieur le ministre vraiment très
intéressant mais aussi très important et
j'ai un tout petit regret c'est que le
garde des sceaux soit pas parmi nous
pour pouvoir nous donner sa position
pour pour ses professions qui sont
finalement dépendants de son ministère
si Madame Didier
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ont fait
comme si c'était pas sur tout le
territoire la même chose on fait comme
si les différents tribunaux de grande
instance traiter globalement toujours
les mêmes affaires qu'on soit à
n'importe quel endroit du territoire on
fait comme si les cabinets d'avocats ou
les différentes professions
judiciaires avaient les mêmes revenus à
Paris à Bordeaux ou à briller dans le
nord de la Meurthe-et-Moselle et le
problème des moyennes c'est qu'elle ne
s'applique à personne
donc moi quand il ne s'agit absolument
pas monsieur le ministre de jouer avec
des peurs c'est pas le problème c'est
que objectivement dans des territoires
assez déshérités comme les nôtres
certains le connaissent nous avons déjà
des difficultés sociales il y a un
tribunal d'instant ce tribunal
fonctionne avec un barreau certes pas
très important mais ça fonctionne et en
tout cas les gens de ce territoire
peuvent
trouver là les services qu'il leur faut
et bien notre collègue a indiqué comme
Alsace il n'y avait aucune difficulté à
aller de colba de Colmar à Strasbourg
tous les territoires là encore ne sont
pas égaux de ce point de vue de la
mobilité et donc nous risquons vraiment
et pas pour faire peur c'est le constat
d'avoir des territoires déshérités et ou
de fait pour avoir accès à ces services
là il faudra tout simplement s'en passer
quand on en a pas les moyens quand c'est
compliqué déjà s'adresser à la justice
c'est quelque chose de pas simple et
bien nous allons organiser des
différences de territoires et là je suis
prête à parier que nous allons vers un
déséquilibre complet en tout cas dans
des territoires
monsieur le ministre vous voulez pas
entendre parler d'expérimentation et
bien en tout cas quand on les décide ce
serait bien que finalement on aille au
bout et je rejoins le rapporteur ce
serait bien et quand ça dit oui que
c'est pas bien il faut pas balayer d'un
verrement mais je vous assure que dans
certains barreaux il n'y aura plus
d'avocats tout simplement il n'y en aura
plus parce que l'équilibre qu'il
trouvait à leur certes la postulation ne
représente pas un volume énorme mais
c'est ça plus ça plus simple ça faisait
quelque chose d'à peu près correct ils
iront tout simplement s'installer à Metz
à Nancy ou à Strasbourg je ne sais où et
de fait on va vers la suppression des
petits tribunaux d'instance ainsi que
des petits barreaux voilà la réalité il
ne s'agit pas de dire qu'on dit
n'importe quoi enfin cette façon de
vouloir discréditer parce qu'on ne dit
pas la même chose que vous je ne suis
pas d'accord
il y a un madame Didier merci Madame
Didier pardon monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
je voulais je voulais d'abord apporter
une réponse complémentaire à monsieur le
rapporteur ce que je l'avais omise sur
la DGCCRF pour dire d'abord qu'il s'agit
en effet d'agents qui sont habilités et
ensuite que le le secret est préservé
puisque les conventions sont anonymisées
dans le cadre du contrôle donc là-dessus
je voulais apporter
c'est marqué nulle part mais si vous
m'en donnez rare ça améliore la chose je
vous je vous en donne je n'avais pris
l'engagement je l'avais précisé puisque
c'est déjà le cas ce sur ce que la
DGCCRF aujourd'hui contrôle puisque cela
existe la législf procède à des
contrôles de la sorte j'avais pris
exactement le même engagement au banc à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc j'ai déjà
clarifié ce point donc ce qui fait que
votre votre audition au de la dgcf a dû
à du confirmer ce dernier moi je me
réjouis que madame la sénatrice
considère que la réponse au fond des
arguments va y exclusion l'argument de
l'autre j'ai plutôt eu le sentiment que
depuis le début de de nos débats c'était
la posture que vous aviez adopté à mon
endroit mais mais c'est parfait si nous
avons ce constat commun cependant je
veux je veux vous dire deux choses je
veux vous dire deux choses par rapport à
ça d'abord détrompez-vous les avocats
les plus pauvres ils sont à Paris ils
sont pas en province aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les chiffres ça c'est le
premier point donc vous faites la
deuxième chose c'est que cette réforme
elle va plutôt baisser le coût pour les
justiciables parce que aujourd'hui la
postulation elle a un coût et donc elle
le baissera la troisième chose c'est que
on ne va pas interdire aux gens d'être
au niveau du TG on va justement
permettre à un avocat qui est dans un
TGI et qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas dans
des affaires civiles à les plaider dans
le TGI voisin ou à la cour d'appel de le
faire
de le faire et c'est pour ça que
l'expérimentation elle ne doit pas être
regardée madame la sénatrice à l'aune du
simple barreau
chiffre qui était donné mais du
professionnel parce que peut-être qu'il
fait moins d'argent au niveau du barreau
initial mais parce qu'il peut aller
plaider ailleurs et donc je ne sais pas
dire aujourd'hui ce qui se passera pour
les professionnels mais il est évident
que on a croit leur possibilité en
matière civile de faire et encore une
fois pour vous rassurer en matière
pénale c'est même pas au niveau de la
cour d'appel c'est France entière
bien
alors je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement numéro 725 présenté par
Monsieur Bigot avec un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté
deux amendements
identiques pour la suite
le 305 rectifié bis monsieur Larcher oui
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le batelier monsieur
le fut rapporteur c'est abonnement vise
à permettre le prononcer par le
bâtonnier de la responsabilité de
l'avocat vis-à-vis de son client quand
il
y a son devoir des formations préalables
sur les conditions de sa rémunération en
effet le bâtonnier est déjà compétent
pour juger du montant des honoraires
dans un souci de simplification la
procédure simplifiée du décret de 1991
auprès du Bâtonnier étant plus rapide
que la procédure judiciaire et afin
d'assurer la pleine d'effectivité des
nouvelles dispositions de la loi
imposant la convention d'honoraires aux
avocats il s'agit de permettre que la
même procédure puisse juger à la fois du
montant des honoraires mais également de
la bonne information initiale sur le sur
un montant il n'est pas simple pour le
consommateur de déterminer à coup sûr
lequel de ces deux interlocuteurs le
bâtonnier ou autorité judiciaire sera
compétent pour trancher un litige je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Larcher le 515 rectifié
n'est pas défendu
quelle est la vie de la commission sur
le 305 rectifié bis le ministre mes
chers collègues
le rôle du Bâtonnier en matière de
contrôle des honoraires est un rôle
d'arbitre il vérifie si les honoraires
dus dans le cadre de l'exécution d'un
mandat son conforme aux usages c'est la
formule habituellement
utilisée mais lorsque la contestation ne
porte non pas sur le chiffrage des
honoraires mais sur le fait que leur
bâtir que l'avocat aurait commis une
faute dans l'exercice de son mandat
c'est une action d'une nature totalement
différente et cet amendement qui
voudrait donner ces deux pouvoirs au
bâtonniers remettra en cause une
jurisprudence constante de la Cour de
cassation
un dernier arrêt si vous voulez de 10
mars 2004 confirmé
par un arrêt du 26 mai 2011 le bâtonnier
n'est pas le juge de la responsabilité
lorsqu'il juge de la responsabilité il
faut qu'il d'abord il trouve une dans
l'exécution du mandat un lien de
causalité un préjudice je vais pas vous
faire
la relation de la mise en oeuvre d'une
responsabilité
ce n'est pas
je ne peux pas émettre un avis favorable
car cela reviendrait à modifier
considérablement le rôle du bétonnier et
en faire et à faire de lui une
juridiction
à part entière ce que me semble-t-il
aucun bâtonnier de France ne souhaite
défavorable monsieur le ministre
je vois exactement les mêmes arguments
et demanderait ou le retrait sinon avis
défavorable
retrait monsieur Larcher très bien donc
on passe maintenant à deux amendements
identiques le 181
tombe et le 197 rectifié monsieur Arnel
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes
dames et
la consultation juridique n'est pas
définie à aucune étape de la
réglementation de l'exercice du doigt
alors qu'elle constitue la pierre
angulaire du dispositif contenu dans la
loi
61 11 30 du 31 décembre 1961 portant
réforme de certaines professions
judiciaires et juridiques pourtant la
consultation judiciaire juridique n'est
pas un acte anodin pour qu'il a
sollicite son exercice a-t-il principal
est réservé aux seuls professionnels
juridique réglementé la proposition de
définition contribue à une clarification
d'eau du champ d'intervention de
l'avocat au bénéfice du citoyen dans la
mesure où elle permettra de réduire de
façon significative les difficultés
d'interprétation que cette absence de
définition de la notion de consultation
juridique a pu générer et les
contentieux qui ont résulté
quelle est la vie de la Commission
a déjà été déposé en commission et
repousser
les auteurs de l'amendement se proposent
de reprendre dans la loi la définition
jurisprudentielle actuelle de la
consultation juridique j'attire
toutefois votre attention sur plusieurs
points le caractère jurisprudentiel de
la définition actuelle ne soulève aucune
difficulté particulière j'observe
d'ailleurs à cet égard qu'il serait
cohérent si on pousse la logique
jusqu'au bout qu'on définisse la
rédaction d'actes sous saint privé qui
constitue l'autre prestation délivrée
avec la consultation par les
professionnels du droit en outre la
définition qui est proposée diffère de
celle de la jurisprudence qui précise
que la consultation juridique peut se
définir je cite comme une prestation
intellectuelle personnalisée qui tend à
fournir un avis parfois un conseil qui
concourt par les éléments qu'il apporte
à la prise de décision du bénéficiaire
de la consultation
c'est une définition très large alors la
définition dès lors proposée pose un
problème délicat vis-à-vis des
obligations de lutte contre le
blanchiment obligation qui sont faites
aux avocats en effet dans le système
track fin les avocats sont exonérées de
toute obligation déclarative s'agissant
des consultations juridiques qu'ils
effectuent pour leurs clients sauf
lorsqu'elles sont directement fournies à
des fins de blanchiment des capitaux ou
de financement du terrorisme ou lorsque
l'avocat sait que son client les demande
à cette fin dans cette perspective
définir trop largement la consultation
juridique en permettant qu'elle puisse
concerner autre chose que des prises de
décision ou en mettant le conseil sur le
même plan que la vie est en champ de
l'exonération de la déclaration Tracfin
et diminue d'autant l'efficacité du
dispositif
avis défavorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre défavorable
également
je vais mettre au voile amendement 197
rectifié avec deux avis défavorables qui
est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté
nous allons passer au vote de l'article
13 il y a-t-il des explications de vote
je n'en vois pas qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 13 est adopté
article 13 bis
deux amendements identiques de
suppression
alors
je vous en prie chers collègues et
Madame Didier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre tout d'abord je
voudrais vous rassurer nous n'avons rien
à titre personnel contre votre personne
donc simplement nous exprimons des
points de vue et je vous invite
d'ailleurs à propos du ce que j'ai dit
précédemment à vous rapprocher de mon de
votre éminent Christian et Ker qui est
sur le même territoire que moi et qui
vous confirmera mes propos par cet
amendement donc de suppression nous
demandons la suppression de l'article 13
bis en effet cet article instant la
liberté d'installation des professions
réglementées du droit revenant sur le
numerus clausus et remplaçant le
dispositif d'autorisation préalable par
un principe de liberté d'installation
encadrée ce dispositif est actuellement
sous contrôle du ministre de la Justice
qui dispose d'une visibilité et d'un
pouvoir stratégique sur une carte de la
justice et qui prend en compte
l'exigence d'accès de tous les citoyens
au service public de la justice nous ne
voyons donc aucune raison de libéraliser
les implantations et de déposséder le
ministre du pouvoir de décision de
nouveaux offices il paraît au contraire
le mieux placé pour décider des
créations de nouveaux offices puisqu'il
disposent seul d'une vision d'ensemble
et d'une capacité de régulation
stratégique qui concernant des
professions réglementées ayant par
délégation des missions de service
public étant l'occurrence tout à fait
approprié là encore l'article 13 bis à
certes été réécrit en commission des
lois dans un sens qui restreint cette
liberté d'implantation mais qui tout en
l'encadrant il la valide et en fait un
principe de fonctionnement légitime la
Commission est limitée cette liberté à
des zones identifiées par le ministère
lui-même et ou un déficit d'office
serait constaté par lui seul ces zones
sont soumises à une liberté totale dans
les autres zones non carencées les
nouvelles implantations ne seraient pas
libres mais soumises à l'approbation de
la ministre bien que ne s'exerçant que
dans les zones où l'implantation
d'office est jugé utile pour renforcer
la proximité ou l'offre de service cette
liberté nous paraît peu compatible avec
les exigences des galaxies les citoyens
la justice partout sur le territoire et
cela risque de fragiliser l'équilibre
existant entre les offices et c'est
pourquoi nous demandons cette
suppression
chers collègues le 771 n'est pas défendu
quelle est la vie de la commission
sur le 15
expression c'est un moment de
suppression nous allons voir avec les
débats suivants éclairer
vos avis qui suivront qui ne changeront
certainement pas mais enfin la vie est
favorable monsieur le ministre le même
je mets au voile amendement numéro 15
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
amendement 1618 du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole
oui
rapidement dire
quels sont les principaux points sur
lequel le gouvernement souhaite modifier
le texte de la commission spéciale du
Sénat sur cet article 13 bis alors
d'abord sur la définition de de ces
zones utiles il est prévu dans le texte
de la commission spéciale que ces zones
sont donc définies par le ministre de la
justice après avis d'autorité de la
concurrence la détermination des zones
telles que proposée par notre amendement
elle vise à dire que l'Autorité de la
concurrence propose une carte donc
objective et que c'est sur cette base
que la décision est prise par les deux
ministres deuxième point c'est le
mécanisme de classement au mérite si
plusieurs candidats à l'installation
existent dans une zone utile c'est
l'alinéa 7
cette mesure nous paraît relever du
niveau réglementaire elle correspond aux
modalités de nomination par le ministre
de la Justice d'un officier public
ministériel et donc là dessus faites pas
qu'elle soit troisième point c'est sur
le refus d'installation dans les
utile par le ministre de la Justice qui
est possible si un nombre suffisant
d'office est intervenu après la
publication de la cartographie ce refus
est rendu sans avis de l'Autorité de la
concurrence il me semble que la libre
installation doit être automatique des
Landes que la zone est déclarée utile
pendant deux ans et le délai court qui
doit justement permettre d'éviter un
surnombre justifie la révision régulière
c'est toutes la philosophie de la
proposition initiale de
du gouvernement qui a été conforté par
le vote à l'Assemblée nationale le
quatrième point il est relatif au
contentieux de l'indemnisation lié à la
perte de valeur patrimoniale de l'Office
qui est confié au juge judiciaire et non
plus au juge de l'expropriation en effet
le conseil est constitutionnel a reconnu
que la valeur d'un office revêtait un
caractère patrimonial dès lors le juge
de l'expropriation peut être compétent
c'est ce que nous voulons ici rétablir
le cinquième point c'est que le fond de
péréquation j'ai eu l'occasion de m'en
expliquer prévu à l'article 12 peut
servir un indemnisation à laquelle le
titulaire d'un nouvel Office est tenu
dans votre alinéa 17 et nous souhaitons
que la teinte à la valeur d'un office
existant par un nouvel entrant et soit
reconnu sur la base d'une analyse locale
et au cas par cas pourquoi c'est
exactement la philosophie que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure parce que si
au bout de 6 ans il s'avère qu'il y a
une perte qu'il faut compenser on
considère quand quelque sorte il y a une
clientèle qui aurait dû être acheté qui
n'a pas été acheté par le professionnel
et donc normal qu'ils viennent le faire
il aura au moins 6 ans d'exercice et
donc sans doute plus de solvabilité
qu'un jeune professionnel qui de toute
façon doit acheter au premier jour une
clientèle lorsqu'il a racheté
voilà les points essentiels je préfère
être synthétique qui différencie enfin
qui sur lesquels cet amendement du
Gouvernement est proposé des changements
au texte qui sort de la Commission et
qui renvoie à ce que j'ai pu décrire
précédemment article 12 c'est pourquoi
je propose de ne pas être plus long et
je veux pleinement rassurer madame la
sénatrice j'ai pu mesurer depuis le
début de nos débat la qualité de ses
échanges
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
alors monsieur le ministre je vous donne
que vous avez été effectivement
synthétique ce qui va m'amener à l'être
un peu moins
monsieur le ministre la commission
spéciale souhaite enfin effectivement
profiter de l'occasion que vous nous
donnez de recueillir des explications
plus précises sur la position du
gouvernement au sujet des modifications
que vous avez apportées
au texte des députés encore une fois je
vous rappelle ce qui me vaudra pas
voler de bois vert de tout à l'heure que
la commission spéciale à valider
certains des principes qui inspirent
cette disposition en les a validé
liberté d'installation encadrée dans les
zones carencées avis de l'Autorité de la
concurrence et indemnisation des
concurrents alors comme à l'article 12
et pour la même raison nous avons
supprimé le principe d'une compétence
partagée entre le ministre de la Justice
et le ministre de l'Économie je me suis
déjà expliqué à plusieurs reprises
vous connaissez notre position
sur le deuxième point sur lequel
j'appelle votre attention et celui
concernant les demandes concurrentes
dans les zones de libre-installation
vous indiquez que c'est du domaine du
règlement j'en suis pas sûr je pense
qu'il faut que la loi le prévoit parce
que le principe c'est la libre
installation il faut que la loi cadre et
donc vous dans ce texte vous ne dites
pas un mot de la situation dans laquelle
dans une zone de libre installation
plusieurs candidats se présenteraient
qu'elle sort il faudrait donner à leur
candidature la commission spéciale a
prévu que le ministre de la Justice
mettent les demandeurs en concours afin
de les classer par ordre de mérite afin
de désigner ceux qui pourront créer un
office on fait avancer les choses
puisque j'ai même lu des amendements qui
voulaient que ce soit le premier qui
dépose son dossier qui est le fils qui
était un petit peu un peu curieux
de la même manière il était nécessaire
de prévoir la situation dans laquelle
compte tenu des créations déjà
intervenues l'offre ou la proximité de
service est devenue deux ans avant que
la carte ait eu le temps d'être révisé
dans ce cas il me paraît qu'il faut
donner décidément ministre de la Justice
toute l'attitude pour refuser les
demandes d'installation qui le sera
encore adressé je suppose que de toute
façon c'est une compétence à laquelle
vous ne tenez pas pouvez-vous monsieur
le mini si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
le dispositif de la commission nous dire
précisément comment vous estimez que ces
demandes concurrentes devraient être
traitées le troisième point sur lequel
je souhaite insister celui des zones
intermédiaires vous allez dit et reconnu
dans plusieurs fois pendant les débats
et vous avez raison qu'il y a trois
zones or le dispositif que vous proposez
on distingue 2
il en laisse une troisième dans l'ombre
parce que entre les zones ou la
proximité ou l'offre de service est
insuffisante et celle où la création
d'anophis nouveau porterait atteinte à
l'exploitation des offices existants il
y a celles où l'offre de service
est satisfaisante et ou un office
pourrait être créé sans forcément
compromettre la qualité du service ni
porter atteinte à l'exploitation
d'autres offices chez l'argile donc la
possibilité de création de fils dans ce
cas là
dans le silence du texte on ne sait pas
quel ministre et a fortiori on ne sait
pas si le ministre de la justice
pourrait ou non refuser une nouvelle
demande de création d'un office une
telle lacune peut-être du juridisme mais
pose la question de la conformité de
cette disposition à la constitution
compte tenu de la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle sur l'incompétence
négative du législateur j'attire votre
association de cheminée sur le fait qu'à
plusieurs reprises à l'Assemblée
nationale et lors de la discussion
générale vous avez évoqué ces trois
zones alors que le texte n'en propose
que deux nous avons comblé cette lacune
enfin le dernier point sur lequel je
souhaiterais que nous ayons une
discussion et celui du dispositif
d'indemnisation des concurrents lésés on
a évoqué
ce point à plusieurs reprises mais
monsieur le ministre le choix du
gouvernement de confier le soin de fixer
alors on fait peut-être du juridisme de
la procédure mais après tout on attend
de nous de faire des maîtres les lois
qui soient compatibles avec celles qui
préexistent
de confier le soins de fixer cette
indemnité au juge de l'expropriation ça
me paraît surprenant parce que certes
s'inspire du dispositif d'indemnisation
des avoués mais il s'agissait à l'époque
de la suppression d'une profession et
d'une indemnisation par l'État pour un
motif d'intérêt général les situations
ne sont pas les mêmes le juge de
l'ex-propriation connaît des litiges en
est entre un particulier et une personne
publique or dans le cas qui nous occupe
il s'agit d'un contentieux entre
personnes privées pour un préjudice sur
une perte de chiffre d'affaires et ça
doit relever de la compétence du
tribunal de grande instance voilà je
serai bien sûr nous serons attentifs aux
réponses exhaustives que vous nous
donnerez ni les vraisemblable que toutes
celles que vous nous donnerez pas nos
attentes c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vais conserver mon avis défavorable
en espérant qu'il ne soit qu'à titre
conservatoire
et le ministre aussi monsieur le
sénateur n'ayez pas peur donc je vais
apporter et les éléments de
clarification demandé par Monsieur
rapporteur d'abord pour dire qu'il y a
bien trois zones dans le texte tel que
nous proposons il y a les zones il y a
les zones précisément carencées
où il y a un appel d'offres qui est
organisé et donc on renvoie en effet au
décret l'organisation de cet appel
d'offres pourquoi forcément faire un
concours il peut y avoir d'autres
critères d'autres conditions donc c'est
ce qu'on propose de définir au niveau
réglementaire vous avez tout à fait
raison de préciser que il s'agit du
garde des sceaux qui doit définir ce
point la deuxième zone c'est cette zone
libre ou on considère que
l'installation d'un nouveau
professionnel ne porte pas atteinte
à l'équilibre des autres professionnels
et là on préserve néanmoins une capacité
de veto parce que c'est pas une liberté
complète d'installation cette deuxième
zone qui est
identifiée par la cartographie et puis
il y a les zones interdites entre
guillemets ou là on considère que toute
nouvelle installation porterait atteinte
donc à
l'équilibre des professionnels qui sont
déjà installés c'est les trois zones qui
sont définies dans ce texte et tel qu'il
est tel qu'il les articule donc je
voulais clarifier ce point ce qui fait
que en effet il y a trois logiques
d'installation pour être parfaitement
clair dans les zones qui sont de manière
manifeste carencée on organise un appel
d'offres qui peut prendre la forme d'un
examen ou tout autre pour que des
professionnels puissent venir
s'installer librement moi je suis
évidemment l'examen peut être une forme
de concours qui est connu d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on crée un office
c'est comme ça qu'on le fait
oui exactement pour les nouveaux offices
ceux qui sont créés mais ce qu'on
constate c'est que les délais sont
parfois très longs et donc il peut y
avoir d'autres procédures qui sont aussi
beaucoup plus souples et qui permettent
d'ailleurs de valoriser les acquis de
l'expérience pour ça qu'il faut être sur
ce plan très vigilant et regarder les
choses parce que on qui on veut faire
accéder enfin à qui on veut laisser la
possibilité d'accéder à la création d'un
office dans ces zones de manière
évidente où on ne porte pas atteinte aux
autres professionnels en place parce
qu'il y a un manque et il y a de la
matière ça peut être à certains notaires
salariés qui voudraient accéder ça peut
être aussi à des jeunes qui voudraient
créer leur office il y a plusieurs
situations différentes qui supposent de
prendre en compte évidemment
l'honorabilité les diplômes etc tout ce
qui est imposé mais également de
valoriser les acquis de l'expérience
donc il faut être vigilant sur les
modalités bon donc c'est pour ça que ça
on le renvoie au réglementaire ensuite
il y a je le disais cette zone
intermédiaire où là on considère que
il y a une installation qui il n'y a pas
de carence il y a une installation qui
doit pouvoir être libre parce qu'elle ne
porte pas atteinte aux équilibres mais
on laisse un droit de veto garde des
sceaux donc il y a une régulation qui
est créée parce que on n'est pas sûr des
résultats et c'est dans ce cas-là qu'on
prévoit en effet un régime
d'undemnisation je le reviendrai pas je
l'ai déjà expliqué mais le juge de
l'expropriation il est prévu dans ce cas
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que recommandé le
Conseil d'État au gouvernement lorsque
échange a eu lieu sur ce texte pourquoi
d'abord parce que il garantit une
apporte une garantie procédurale et
ensuite parce qu'il s'agit de perte de
valeur patrimoniale pour précisément un
professionnel en place qui pourrait
prouver après six années qu'il y a une
perte de valeur patrimoniale parce qu'un
jeune vient de s'installer et donc c'est
pour ces deux raisons que nous
organisons enfin qu'on nous prévoyons la
compétence du juge de l'expropriation
enfin dans la troisième zone pour être
parfaitement clair on ne change rien
c'est à dire que on reste dans le
système actuel où vous avez des
professionnels qui quand ils veulent
céder la place et bien avec le droit de
présentation soumettent leur succession
garde des sceaux qui l'acceptent ou pas
et qui permet en tout cas la succession
de l'Office voilà l'organisation qui est
prévue voilà pourquoi nous avons
référence fait référence au juge de
l'expropriation et voilà aussi pourquoi
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a ce rôle
que j'évoquais parce qu'elle pardon
voilà non non mais je je redisais
qu'elle avait ce rôle de d'objectivation
et j'aurais dû le dire d'ailleurs dans
la présentation de cet amendement vous
avez en effet sur tous ces points pour
suivi la logique du texte du
Gouvernement et je vous en remercie nous
avons ces points de sensibilité sur sur
certains aménagements mais vous n'avez
pas remis en effet en cause ça plusieurs
fondamentaux de ce texte mais je crois
que c'est vraiment sur ces trois zones
que j'évoque et ce mécanisme qui a ce
léger des accords qui m'a conduit à
présenter cet amendement
merci Monsieur des Essarts vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le ministre de vos
explications mais
c'est toujours l'inconvénient d'avoir
une bonne explication c'est que elle
rend les choses lisibles et elle nous
permet justement de voir
de nous questionner
vous définissez trois zones et puis vous
dites suivant ces zones on met le paquet
on permet que ça se fasse une zone on
calme et puis une zone bon on
expérimente un peu bon gros
mais qu'est-ce qui empêche de faire
aujourd'hui
c'est la garde des sceaux qui a le qui a
la possibilité de créer des études
donc qu'est-ce qui empêche de dire ben
je fais mes zones alors à moins que vous
disiez
ce que je n'ai pas entendu
les ministères sont tellement bloqués
qu'on n'ose plus rien faire et à ce
moment-là faut qu'il y ait une loi pour
débloquer la situation ça peut être une
explication ou alors vous dites monsieur
Premier ministre aidez-moi à convaincre
et allons-y avec madame la ministre de
la Justice pour que on relance le on
relance le
garde des sceaux qu'on puisse relancer
le processus mais qu'est-ce qui empêche
de le faire puisque la création
aujourd'hui des études se fait par le
par le gouvernement
après donc là qu'est-ce qui empêche le
gouvernement de faire des zones et dans
ces zones de lancer les appels d'offres
ou non ça c'est la première chose
ensuite c'est il y avait quelque chose
de pas clair excusez-moi de vous dire
cela comme ça monsieur le ministre et je
voudrais pas que vous disiez que je ne
veux pas maintenir un contact un
dialogue parce que on aura l'occasion de
se fâcher la semaine prochaine mais
donc je voudrais continuer la semaine
aujourd'hui dans un bon rapport de
puisque là visiblement il y avait des
explications intéressantes mais
monsieur le ministre vous dites faut que
ça soit des jeunes bon alors j'entends
actuellement les on demande quand même
au notaire il passe un certain nombre de
temps et ensuite ils font il y a des
gaines études qui se libèrent les
salariés ou
les claires peuvent postuler pour et pas
se croire c'est pas un examen concours
enfin c'est un concours c'est à dire
c'est celui qui est pris pour prendre
l'étude donc alors vous dites il faut
tenir compte de l'expérience donc c'est
là je peux le comprendre ça veut dire
c'est la remise en cause du concours ou
est-ce que ce sont des critères en plus
de concours qui est pour tenir compte de
l'expérience bon j'ai pas tellement bien
compris ce que vous vouliez dire et
après vous dites faut que ce soit les
jeunes alors là je dis les jeunes qu'on
l'expérience qu'est-ce qui veut dire
exactement donc alors si vous voulez
dire que c'est un brachage général qu'il
faut jeûne expérience et tout je veux
bien comprendre mais alors qu'est-ce qui
change par rapport aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui empêche de le faire
ou alors vous remettez en cause le
concours
et donc à ce moment-là le concours comme
l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur dans la
matinée ou un moment donné il est
l'avantage que c'est pas obligatoire le
fils de l'archevêque je reprends son
expression et donc ça veut dire que le
concours il a cette particularité que
tout le monde peut le passer
et si vous introduisez d'autres critères
pourquoi alors tout ça je vous remercie
de vous expliquer mais comme je vous
l'ai dit lorsque des fois on est trop
transparent et qu'on donne trop
d'explications ça donne prise aux
interlocuteurs pour vous poser des
questions complémentaires
bien
y a-t-il d'autres demandes de parole
je vais mettre au voile amendement du
Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre voulait prendre la
parole
d'abord pour dire que en effet
aujourd'hui on voit bien que le système
est bloqué je le disais instant donc il
faut créer les conditions d'une plus
grande objectivité pour l'ouvrir c'est
ce que vient faire ce texte et
d'ailleurs ce que permettront de faire
les deux textes parce que même le texte
de la commission spéciale disait on a
des désaccords mais il permet déjà de
débloquer les choses parce que on crée
les conditions d'une objectivité
puisque on voit bien que les
professionnels eux-mêmes ont reconnu en
2009 je le disais quand il y a eu des
discussions avec les précédents
gouvernement qu'il fallait
ouvrir l'accès à la profession ça n'a
pas été fait
ça n'a pas été fait
l'Île-de-France demandait à votre
président de commission spéciale s'il y
a eu des créations massives d'office
notariaux en Seine-Saint-Denis il en
manque profondément et vous aussi madame
la Présidente il en manque profondément
dans sa région on les connaît les
déserts notariaux donc le système est
bloqué là on crée les conditions d'une
plus grande transparence d'une plus
grande objectivité et il est bloqué
parce que voilà il y a un jeu d'acteur
qui s'est progressivement constitué mais
après année et on connaît ces résultats
on l'a dans différents secteurs de
sociologie si je puis dire administratif
professionnel donc c'est
la raison d'être de cette réforme que
nous portons avec la garde des sceaux le
deuxième point que vous évoquez j'ai
peut-être été insuffisamment clair et
donc je voulais ici le repréciser se
dire on veut permettre l'accès à la
création d'office de certains
professionnels
et l'accès à la création d'office ça
peut être des jeunes diplômés qui ont
toutes les conditions de diplôme de
stage d'honorabilité donc reconnu
justement toutes ces critères là sont
clairement sous l'autorité de la garde
des sceaux qui veulent accéder à la
création d'un office et donc ils
pourront être candidats dans ces zones
carencées mais en même temps si on ne
crée par exemple qu'un concours de type
académique
vous voyez bien l'avantage du du jeune
diplômé frais moulu qui est au fait
précisément peut-être des dernières des
dernières jurisprudences qui seraient le
candidat idéal à ce nouveau concours
mais vous fermeriez la porte en tout cas
vous créeriez une forme de désavantage à
d'autres notaires qui sont aujourd'hui
dans des offices notaires salariés qui
veulent pouvoir accéder précisément à la
création d'office parce que un notaire
salarié aujourd'hui il peut passer sa
carrière entière sans être plus que
salarié et les différences de
rémunération sont substantielles entre
un notaire salarié et un notaire associé
je ne parle pas d'un notaire qui a son
propre Office pour être associé il faut
que le notaire qui tient l'Office vous
propose c'est le critère même
d'affection société qui préside et donc
cet accès dans la main de celui qui vous
emploie et donc il faut qu'on puisse
aussi ouvrir l'accès au notaire salariés
à la création d'un office public donc il
faut que ce soit une liberté aujourd'hui
qu'il a et donc c'est pourquoi je suis
prudent sur les modalités ça peut être
un examen de type académique ça peut
être un appel d'offres ça peut être un
examen enfin un concours qui va prendre
en compte à la fois les compétences
académiques et valoriser les acquis de
l'expérience pas forcément par
définition pour faire ce brassage mais
je crois que il y a un travail très fin
que doit faire la Chancellerie à cet
effet pour qu'on puisse aménager les
conditions d'un juste accès mais qui
prennent en compte les aspirations de
l'ensemble des professionnels du secteur
voilà le clarification que je pouvais
apporter
monsieur Bigot vous souhaitiez prendre
la parole
oui je voudrais simplement dire que la
présidente prise dans la commission je
déplore que ce débat extrêmement
technique
entre le ministre et notre rapporteur se
fasse ici à l'heure qu'il aurait pu
avoir lieu en commission si nous avions
choisi non pas d'associer le ministre à
tous les travaux on était d'accord
là-dessus mais d'auditionner le ministre
en commission pour échanger sur ces
points car franchement dans le détail
est-ce que c'est le juge de
l'expropriation ou un autre magistrat du
tribunal de grande instance de façon
juste d'être présentation est un
magistral tribunal de grande instance
c'est des détails ça donne le sentiment
que alors qu'on est d'accord sur le fond
on veut pinailler sur les points de
détail pour dire c'est plutôt nous qui
l'avons fait plutôt que le ministre je
trouve que ça n'a pas d'intérêt c'est un
peu dommage et je pense que c'est débats
très techniques qu'on aurait pu les
avoir en commission
merci Monsieur capocanella si vous avez
la parole
je suis un peu lassé d'entendre au fil
des débats et je paraît jusque là que la
Commission aurait pas passé assez de
temps la Commission a été constituée dès
le mois de janvier la Commission a
différentes assemblées nationales a
choisi de faire des auditions qui ont
été nombreuses la conviction la
Commission a convié l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement concernés par ce
texte et le gouvernement je le remercie
a bien voulu accepter à la différence de
l'assemblée que les membres du
gouvernement concernés notamment la
garde des sceaux viennent et viennent
longuement devant chacun d'entre vous et
vous avez eu la liberté d'interroger le
garde des sceaux le rapporteur comme
chacun de ses collègues face à chacun
des ministres l'a fait nous avons le
travail très approfondie nous avons
également pris le temps d'examiner le
texte proposé par chacun des rapporteurs
et les amendements assez longuement je
vous rappelle que nous n'avons pas
consommé le temps qui nous était imparti
là-dessus chacun a fait des efforts une
période pré électorale pas évidente mais
nous avions encore du temps disponible
pour les travaux en commission nous
n'avons jamais écourté les débats sur ce
point et le rapporteur a été celui qui
avait d'ailleurs la matière la plus
juridique c'était évident la matière la
plus complexe il a toujours pris le
temps sur chacun des sujets comme il
vient de le faire à l'instant et depuis
deux heures maintenant il a toujours
pris le temps d'exposer sa vision et de
laisser chacun débattre là-dessus et
j'ai veillé à ce que le débat est mieux
alors après vous nous dites qu'il y a
des points de détails qui surgissent du
débat avec le ministre moi je pense que
en droit et sur ces sujets là les points
de détails n'en sont pas le diable étant
dans les détails chacun le sait et ça
mérite qui est une discussion publique
qui est enrichie nous avons une
tradition au Sénat et j'ai entendu les
demandes y compris de votre groupe dès
le départ pour dire que lors de l'examen
des amendements des rapporteurs
et bien c'était sans la présence du
ministre mais ça a été dans ce cadre-là
et y compris votre groupe en tout cas
par la voix notamment de l'ancien
président de la commission des lois nous
l'avait et précédemment demandé voilà et
le ministre a bien voulu comprendre que
c'était la tradition du Sénat je pense
que la panure au travail parlementaire
mais nous souhaitions aussi que le débat
vraiment puisse prospérer en séance
comme vous le faites maintenant et je
vous en remercie c'est utile parce que
la séance publique doit rester quand
même aussi le moment où chacun des
sénateurs peut s'exprimer et il y a des
sénateurs qui ne sont pas membres de la
commission spéciale qui ont pu
s'exprimer et qui peuvent apporter aussi
leur contribution au débat je crois que
c'est particulièrement utile
vous avez la parole
je ne peux pas encore une fois ne pas
réagir
au cours de ces auditions 70 j'en ai
fait 70 certaines je les ai faites deux
fois ouverte à tous ouverte à tous
certaines à me demandent je les ai
réitéré ouverte pour savoir si ce que je
proposais était sérieux ou pas était
admissible ou pas et en ce qui concerne
le travail que nous avons pu faire avec
le ministère des Finances je tiens à
rappeler que outre outre l'audition de
Monsieur le Ministre en audition
solennelle de la commission nous avons
eu une audition que j'ai fait moi-même
avec le cabinet
et qui était ouverte à tout le monde
et après il y a eu deux auditions
particulières et à ma demande et que
monsieur le ministre a eu également
appris le rose initiatives de me
demander de venir dans une autre
audition informelle
tropiction plus une ça fait 5 avec le
ministère alors on a et vous pouviez
dire mais vous pouviez dire c'est
peut-être la seule fois du coup je vous
ai pas entendu
ah bah ça c'est avec le ministre donc
nous avons nous avons évoqué tous ces
points et je ne veux pas encore une fois
entendre dire parce que vous vous avez
décidé d'en revenir brutalement au texte
de l'Assemblée que nous avancées sont
insuffisantes alors qu'on est les seuls
qui en avons fait j'ai encore une fois
et je remercie le ministre je remercie
son cabinet chaque fois que j'ai demandé
une audition je l'ai eu et le ministre
on a rajouté une personnelle
supplémentaire lors de sa propre
invitation je vous passe les rencontres
qui peuvent avoir de temps en temps
lieux à la suspension pour s'entendre ou
essayer de s'entendre sur différents
points des des articles et puis enfin
vous avez dit que le travail
parlementaire était peut-être vous
risquez de de ne pas admettre les
détails le travail parlementaire c'est
aussi un travail de détail
merci madame de roche vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente vous avez dit
Monsieur Bigot chers
un débat très technique mais en même
temps tous les uns et les autres dans
nos départements quel que soit notre
formation vous vous êtes avocat moi je
suis médecin de formation certains sont
chefs d'entreprise chacun sa formation
nous avons tous dans nos
circonscriptions étaient sollicité
depuis des mois par les professeurs
réglementés et sincèrement moi je suis
heureuse et je pense que beaucoup de mes
collègues partagent cette satisfaction
de pouvoir cet après-midi entendre et le
rapporteur et le ministre chacun d'entre
vous s’exprimer sur ces sujets nous
avons tous été sollicités ce n'était pas
qu'un débat de commission et moi je suis
heureuse que dans cette hémicycle on
puisse enfin débattre de ce sujet qui
était quand même un des points forts de
la loi que nous examinons en ce moment
merci chers collègues je vais donc
mettre au voile amendement du
Gouvernement avec avis défavorable de la
commission
qui est pour l'amendement
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
j'ai maintenant 25 amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
25 je dis bien 25 le 363 rectifié madame
de Seine
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue c'est amendement
et dans le même esprit que celui déposé
à l'article 12 qui n'a pas été adopté en
conséquence je retire le présentement
merci beaucoup le 199 rectifiés monsieur
Arnel
mais nous sommes dans la même logique
mais comme nous souhaitons rester là la
cohérence nous estimons quand même que
l'argumentation est la même que
précédemment l'Autorité de la
concurrence ne doit pas voir ses
attributions étendues de manière si
extensive qu'elles deviendrait
collégiative de notre réglementation
très bien donc
madame de scène
le 282 même voilà je le retire monsieur
Navarro n'est pas là donc le 414 n'est
pas défendu
le 634 rectifié bis madame Grigny
elle n'est pas là
il y a pas de donc il n'est pas défendu
le 1063 je vous en prie cher collègue
merci
le ministre mes chers collègue de la
même manière que nous sommes opposés
lors de l'examen de l'article 12 à
l'introduction de l'Autorité de la
concurrence dans la procédure de
détermination des tarifs des professions
réglementées nous opposons ici à son
introduction dans la réflexion
concernant l'élaboration de cartes
relatives aux zones d'implantation des
nouveaux offices des professeurs
réglementés parce qu'il y a de cautionne
pas les activités purement marchandes
parce qu'elles traite du rapport des
citoyens au droit à l'accès à la justice
parce qu'elles sont sans être
complètement sous la tutelle du
ministère réglementé par lui pour
garantir la réalisation des missions de
service public dans le respect de
l'intérêt général c'est très
responsabilité ne peut incomber à
l'Autorité de la concurrence ainsi nous
retrouvons au sein de cet article
traitant de la réglementation de
l'installation des professions
juridiques de l'intervention de
l'autorité de la concurrence
elle donne un avis sur la carte établi
par le ministre de la Justice pour
déterminer les zones où l'implantation
et la création de nouveaux offices est
libres en raison d'un besoin
identifié de renforcement de proximité
ou de l'offre il est également prévu
dans les aldinéades à 19 à 22 que le
garde des sceaux puissent saisir pour
avis l'Autorité de la concurrence sur
toute question relatives à la liberté
d'installation des notaires huissier de
justice et commissaire-priseur
judiciaire et qu'elle puisse adresser
des recommandations au ministre sur
l'augmentation du nombre d'offices sur
le territoire nous demandons donc la
suppression de toute introduction de
l'Autorité de la concurrence dans cet
article et dans la problématique
d'installation et de création d'office
de professeurs réglementés cette
autorité administrative est un effet ni
légitime ni compétent dans la matière sa
vocation exclusivement économique et
idéologique puisqu'elle doit favoriser
la libre concurrence guidée par le dogme
de l'autorégulation théorisé é par la
danse vite sur le nom de main invisible
ce qui en l'occurrence est antinomique
avec des missions de délégation de
services publics réglementés qui par
définition ne peuvent être entièrement
concurrentielles en la matière le
meilleur interlocuteur reste encore le
ministre terre de la justice et
l'intervention de l'autorité de la
concurrence loin de lui être utile
introduit un premier jalon de la volonté
de libéralisation de ces professions que
nous combattons je vous remercie
bien alors merci le 340 n'est pas
défendu
le 284 rectifiés monsieur metvielle
il est défendu
madame de scène peut-être
284 rectifiés quater
oui madame la Présidente ce projet de
loi en tant imposé à toute personne
sollicitant son installation en tant que
notaire de justifier notamment de
conditions d'expérience les dispositions
actuelles régissant la nomination des
notaires impose la possession d'un
diplôme d'aptitude fonction de notaire
ce qui assure la qualité des candidats
et permet l'équité la seule référence à
l'expérience ne peut suffire pour
l'exercice d'une délégation de puissance
publique c'est pourquoi il est proposé
de remplacer les mots d'expérience par
les mots de diplôme
le 374 rectifié n'est pas défendu
idem pour le 4016 pour le 567 rectifiés
le 661
oui
il a été défendu c'était le même
abonnement que celui présenté par ma
collègue c'est moins cher collègue alors
le 671 rectifié bis il y a bien personne
le 118 rectifié
idem le 365 aussi le 341 aussi donc je
passe maintenant 229 rectifiés monsieur
Arnel
iste Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs le président allemand pour
objet de préciser que le ministre de la
justice doit pouvoir refuser la demande
de création s'il est avéré que cette
création est de nature apportée atteinte
à la continuité de l'exploitation des
offices existants ou à compromettre la
qualité du service rendu
merci le 283 rectifiés quater madame de
Seine
madame la Présidente chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
cet amendement a pour objet la nécessité
que le ministre de la Justice ne puisse
que refuser la demande de création s'il
est avéré que cette création est de
nature à portée atteinte à la continuité
de l'exploitation des offices existants
ou à compromettre la qualité du service
rendu en effet dès lors qu'il n'y a pas
de carence il n'est pas justifié
d'envisager la possibilité d'une
installation dans ces conditions la
garde des sceaux doit refuser
si le 372 rectifiés madame Duchêne
amendement identique
merci
ensuite le 415 tombe
le 651 rectifié bis tombent également
le 1061 madame assassis merci madame la
Présidente c'est une véritable hécatombe
cet après-midi d'amendement
l'article 13 bises dans sa nouvelle
rédaction crée des systèmes de zones
avec des zones d'implantation libres qui
sont déterminées par le ministre et qui
correspondent à des secteurs où le
nombre d'office parraient insuffisants
et où l'implantation de nouveaux offices
pourraient renforcer la proximité
juridique dans les autres zones où
l'implantation est donc pas libre la loi
prévoit que le ministre de la Justice
peut refuser une demande de création
d'office pourtant s'il ne s'agit pas
d'une zone ou une éventuelle carence a
été constatée le ministre n'a aucune
raison d'autoriser l'ouverture d'un
nouvel Office et cette autorisation
déstabiliserait l'équilibre des offices
existants au delà autoriser ces
implantations dans des zones non
prioritaires alors même que c'est le
ministère qui définit lui-même ces zones
les zones où il y a un besoin de
création paraît complètement illogique
maintenir cette alinéa en l'état c'est
donc conserver le principe de
dérégulation en excusez-moi mais
peut-être en voulant le camoufler
c'est pourquoi nous proposons que dans
ces zones le ministre refuse
systématiquement toute création d'office
nous proposons donc cet amende avec cet
amendement de conserver l'idée de deux
zones distinctes et de n'autoriser la
liberté d'installation contrôlée par le
ministre que dans les zones
identifiées par lui comme ayant une
offre insuffisante en matière de
profession juridique
merci beaucoup alors ensuite nous
passons 119 rectifié
qu'il n'est pas soutenu
un autre amendement identique monsieur
Arnel c'est le 230 rectifié
il ressemble étrangement madame la
Présidente à un autre mais je me fais
fort quand même de le
de le lire puisque il me semble que ça
porte quand même une note supplémentaire
au débat le projet de loi prévoit que le
ministre de la justice pourra faire
droit à la demande de création d'office
de notaire d'huissiers de justice ou le
commissaire-priseur judiciaire qui lui
est adressé lorsque le demandeur rempli
par ailleurs les conditions de
nationalité d'aptitude d'honorabilité
d'expérience et d'assurance requise cela
signifie concrètement que ces
nominations seront discrétionnaires et
que rien ne garantit que le candidat
détienne les compétences nécessaires à
l'exercice des missions de notaire
d'huissier de justice ou le
commissaire-priseur judiciaire quid de
la qualité du conseil qui sera dispensé
au client
aujourd'hui cette année d'études après
baccalauréat sont nécessaires pour
devenir notaire après des études
juridiques master bac + 4 les aspirants
notaires doivent choisir entre deux
types de formation l'université l'autre
professionnel avec dans les deux cas un
stage obligatoire et rémunéré pour les
huissiers une maîtrise et un master en
droit ou un diplôme reconnu comme
équivalent à la maîtrise de droit puis
un stage de deux années clôturé par le
passage à l'examen
sont nécessaires pour les commissaires
priseur judiciaires deux diplômes sont
nécessaires pour pouvoir s'inscrire à
l'examen de commissaire-priseur le
non-droit et l'autre en histoire de
l'art en art d'appliquer en archéologie
où on a en plastique l'un de ces
diplômes doit être au moins une licence
et l'autre un bac + domine puis 90 euros
sont demandés à titre de l'inscription à
l'examen ce qui devrait être supprimé
afin de garantir un égal accès de tout à
cet examen public ces exigences
scolaires sont donc loin d'être
superflues quand on connaît la
complexité du doigt et l'importance que
le conseil juridique aura pour ceux qui
le demandent si le nécessaire d'ouvrir
ses professions il est également
salutaire de préserver leur niveau
d'exigence en matière de compétence
si chers collègues amendement identique
monsieur Tandonnet
qu'un grand nombre d'amendements
sollicite de remplacer le mot
d'expérience par le mot diplôme c'est
vrai que dans les différentes
professions le cette référence à
l'expérience à suscité beaucoup de
préoccupations et c'est ce qui justifie
le nombre d'amendements similaire
ce sont des professions réglementées qui
dans lesquelles les diplômes sont
essentiels pour accéder à ces
professions alors je pense que ce qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui c'est que monsieur
le ministre nous apporte une
clarification et que dans les conditions
requises pour accéder à ses professions
il est mentionné l'aptitude donc je
suppose que l'aptitude recouvre la
notion de diplôme je crois que ça il
faudrait le dire clairement ça
permettrait de rassurer les
professionnels et peut-être de retirer
l'ensemble de ces amendements en tout
cas il y a vraiment une inquiétude sur
ce problème de diplôme et donc je crois
qu'il faut rassurer les professionnels
merci Madame non pardon
oui merci Madame à présent monsieur le
ministre dans la même veine nous voulons
rappeler aussi que cet article tout en
introduisant la déréglementation des
implantations et la création des offices
dans certaines zones qui pourraient
remettre en cause l'exigence d'un
diplôme dans l'accès aux professions de
notaire huissiers et à l'ensemble des
professions juridiques réglementées et
ainsi déréglementer l'accès assez
professions l'alinéa 21 de cet article
fait référence aux personnes remplissant
les conditions de nationalité
d'aptitudes d'honorabilité d'expériences
et d'assurance requises pour être nommée
par le ministre de la Justice dans les
différentes professions précédemment
évoquées aucune condition de diplôme
n'est ainsi clairement évoquée ça vient
d'être dit par mon collègue étant donné
la notion d'aptitude étant bien trop
floue ces conditions d'aptitudes
d'expérience ne paraissent pas à même de
pouvoir garantir la qualité
professionnelle et de formation des
personnes
exerçant des professions chargées de
mission de service public relevant de la
justice j'ai noté d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre que dans une de vos
interventions vous avez bien utilisé le
mot diplôme par contre le projet de loi
en tant imposé à toute personne
sollicitant son installation en tant que
notaire commissaire-priseur huissier de
justifier d'une durée d'expérience ce
qui limite l'entrée des jeunes dans la
profession concernant les notaires les
dispositions actuelles qui régissent
leur nomination imposent la pose la
possession d'un diplôme d'aptitude aux
fonctions de notaire ce qui assure la
qualité des candidats et permet l'équité
dans l'accès à la profession et la bonne
réalisation du service rendu dans une
vocation d'intérêt général et ils y sont
attachés la seule référence à
l'expérience ne peut pas suffire pour
l'exercice d'une délégation de puissance
publique il faut qu'un diplôme
garantit l'acquisition d'un certain
nombre de compétences contrôlées c'est
pourquoi il vous est proposé comme les
autres amendements de remplacer le mot
d'expérience par le mot diplôme
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
nous allons prendre ces amendements pour
avoir votre avis alors d'abord le 199
rectifiés alors le 199
merci beaucoup ah oui bon cette
même le micro n'en veut plus
cette amendement vise à supprimer la vie
de l'Autorité de la concurrence pour la
définition des zones carnes ou
l'installation d'un office serait libre
alors évidemment compte tenu de tous les
débats qu'il y a eu l'après-midi vous me
pardonnerez mais la vie est défavorable
sans autre commentaire
excusez-moi j'ai pas bien entendu
défavorable le 1063
idem il est exactement le même même
commentaire avis défavorable
284 rectifiés quatters
un amendement qui concerne la condition
d'expérience
requise pour devenir notaire ici comme
surpriseur notaire pour la remplacer par
une condition de diplôme or là je suis
ferme
cette condition de diplôme est d'ores et
déjà incluse dans celle d'aptitude donc
le problème était est réglé on note en
outre en outre supprimer toute référence
à la notion d'expérience pourrait
conduire à autoriser la titularisation
de diplômés qui n'aurait jamais accompli
de stage professionnel or actuellement
ce stage et par exemple de deux ans pour
le Diplôme Supérieur du Notariat pour
sans doute évacuer des craintes qui sont
derrière cet amendement j'ajoute que
d'ores et déjà d'ores et déjà le droit
en vigueur prévoit la validation des
acquis de l'expérience
d'éclairs de nos terres des magistragés
de mandataire judiciaire ou d'avocats et
donc finalement l'amendement proposé
serait en retrait par rapport aux droits
en vigueur donc je pense que vous avez
tout apaisement sur cette question je
vous suggère des retirer enfin que je
n'ai pas aimé être un avis défavorable
bon c'est pareil pour le 374 donc
ensuite le 229 rectifié
un certain nombre d'amendements
également sur cette question ou les
auteurs voudraient obliger le ministre
de la Justice a refusé tout installation
dans une zone autre que carrée
je répète que il y a trois zones et
qu'il y en a une qui n'est pas carencé
où il faut laisser la souplesse ce
faisant d'ailleurs ils sont en retrait
par rapport au droit en vigueur et à
titre d'exemple ils interdiraient aux
garde des sceaux de décider de la
création d'un nouvel Office dans une
grande ville où à Paris moi j'ajoute
qu'en tout état de cause il me paraît
raisonnable de conserver au Nice de la
justice une certaine liberté
d'appréciation le chemise des finances
nous a indiqué tout à l'heure que
d'ailleurs il n'en n'avait pas abusé
pendant la période antérieure au dépôt
du projet de loi
ensuite
230 rectifiées
ils sont identiques ils sont identiques
même avis
372 mais ma vie ma vie
1061 même avis
non on revient au diplôme dans le 230
rectifié
idem pour le 650 rectifié bis et les
retiré et
idem pour la l'amendement 1062 en
définitive en résumé en conclusion pour
l'ensemble de ces amendements je
sollicite qu'il soit retiré à défaut des
avis défavorables vous vous ne retirerez
pas les vôtres donc la vie est
défavorable
très bien monsieur le ministre ma vie
alors retirer le mot 199 rectifiés avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
alors maintenant le
qui est pour
avis défavorable tout le temps qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
284 rectifiés quarter même votre
le 374 est identique donc même vote
ensuite 229 rectifiés avec le 283 372
1061 qui sont identiques
avis donc défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
le 230 rectifié et tous les identiques à
vider deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
favorable qui est pour
je l'avais pas mis en voix celui-là
c'est pour ça
on confirme qu'il est rejeté on est bien
d'accord bien
monsieur des Essarts le 971
non
je voulais dire défendre le 971
l'autre est tombé
la liberté d'installation accordée par
ce texte va permettre au ministère de la
Justice de définir des zones
prioritaires d'installation dans
laquelle l'installation sera libre et le
système serait suffisamment encadré pour
éviter les dérives dans les zones déjà
correctement dotées le ministère de la
Justice peut refuser les nouvelles
installations dans ces conditions il n'y
a pas lieu de créer un système
d'indemnisation des offres préexistants
d'une part parce que les garanties que
je viens d'évoquer sont nos natures
suffisantes pour éviter les dérives et
d'autre part parce que cela
découragerait l'installation de nouveaux
entrants à cause du risque pesant sur
leur activité à la vue du niveau
d'indemnisation que l'on pourrait leur
réclamer jusqu'à 6 ans après leur
installation il est également noté que
le maintien de ces dispositions
signerait un manque de confiance dans
l'administration de la justice puisque
celle-ci pourrait être mise en question
donc l'idée nous en avons débattu ce
matin monsieur le ministre vous dites il
faut indemniser parce qu'il y a une
perte au bout de 6 ans s'apercevrait
qu'il y aurait une perte de revenus des
études alentours bon
c'est un peu contraire avec votre idée
qu'il faut installer des nouveaux dans
les endroits où il y a besoin c'est un
peu contraire à votre idée de dire il y
a il faut améliorer la qualité puisque
si il y a un notaire qui répond jamais
au téléphone qui traite les affaires
avec beaucoup de retard je ne dis pas
que c'est de l'ensemble de la profession
mais comme dans tout profession on peut
pas dire que tout le monde est
formidable parce que il a le l'étiquette
notaire donc il y a effectivement un
contrôle enfin il y a une qualité donc
l'idée d'installer des nouvelles
personnes qui prendraient
une clientèle parce que justement ils
sont
jeunes serviables compétent actif à
disposition et cela il va dire bon
l'autre là qui travaillait mal et tout
il faut l'indemniser enfin il y a
vraiment un petit un petit problème quoi
donc et d'autant plus d'autant plus que
vous nous avez dit ce matin que il
fallait payer les charges donc quand une
étude se crée aujourd'hui
et bien il y a possibilité de
s'installer puis la personne fait sa
clientèle quoi donc
c'était un peu contradictoire avec votre
esprit libéral monsieur
le ministre
le 594 rectifié n'est pas défendu donc
quelle est la vie de la commission sur
le 971
mon cher collègue il faut bien
différencier faut pas faire de confusion
entre certaines professions libérales
comme les avocats et les notaires ils
sont pas de même nature lorsque vous
installez un nouveau notaire vous créez
un office vous créez un vous lui donnez
droit à un monopole et se faisant vous
affecter le monopole de ceux qui sont
déjà en place donc
l'indemnisation est de droit et si vous
importe si vous supprimez
l'indemnisation un petit problème
constitutionnel car
vous aurez en quelque sorte
léser ceux qui sont titulaires déjà d'un
monopole sur le point en revanche pour
un invocation uniquement parce que vous
créez un monopole un avocat il a passé
l'examen il achète sa plaque il la met
sur sur la façade de l'immeuble et puis
terminé mais en l'espèce je peux mettre
qu'un avis défavorable parce que ce
serait même anticonstitutionnel
bien monsieur le ministre défavorable
très bien je vais mettre au voile
l'amendement de Monsieur de Essarts
numéro
9611 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté
l'amendement 339 n'est pas défendu
je vais donc mettre au voile l'article
y a-t-il des explications de vote donc
monsieur Bigot je vous en prie vous avez
la parole
non non chers collègue je reconnais avec
mon groupe à la Commission le fait
qu'elle n'a pas voulu complètement
empêcher l'installation de nouveaux
notaires et répondre à ses besoins fixés
dans la loi et dans le projet de loi je
regrette bien évidemment que sur
certains points on n'est pas trouvé un
accord je dois dire qu'à titre personnel
je suis plus sensible à la vie de
l'Autorité de la concurrence qu'à la
proposition mais tout ça on aurait pu en
discuter un autre moment donc notre
groupe sur ce point là pour reconnaître
aussi le travail qui a été fait va
s'abstenir il ne va pas votre écran de
toute façon ça changera pas grand chose
le résultat et personnellement je vais
rentrer serein dans mon département
puisque de toute façon il est prévu à la
nuit à 24 de l'article 13 bis qui ne
s'implique pas dans les départements
d'Alsace et de Moselle donc je suis
entre serein
merci y a-t-il d'autres prises de parole
bien je vais mettre au voile l'article
13 bis qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 13 bis est adopté voilà vous
venez de suivre les débats sur le projet
de loi croissance activités et égalité
des chances économiques il portait plus
précisément sur le volet sur les
professions réglementées les sénateurs
ont pris beaucoup de retard dans
l'examen de ce texte il reprendront leur
travail d'examen des amendements à
partir du 4 mai prochain en vue du vol
solennelle qui a été décalé au 12 mai
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
cette séance et toutes les autres sur
notre site public sénat.fr très bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires